first thing you want to recognize is
your basic formula of how to analyze the
tangent graph so this a value what that
does is it stretches the graph or
compresses the graph what the H does
it's a phase shift that shifts the graph
left and right but this has the opposite
effect so if you have like X minus Pi
the negative PI is actually going to be
going to the right positive PI if this
is plus PI it's actually going to be
going to the left negative pi and then
the K is a vertical shift so that's
going to shift it up and down so if this
is plus one which shifted up one minus
one would shift to down one and then
what this B value does is it affects the
horizontal stretch or compress basically
affecting the period and we can use this
formula right here period equals PI and
divided by B now when we graph tangent
we look at these key values from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
so on our unit circle and remember
tangent is the Y value divided by the x
value Y divided by X and so on
so over here at a negative PI over 2
when you do Y divided by X negative 1
divided by 0 is undefined because you
can't divide by 0 so what that means is
we get a vertical asymptote right there
at negative PI over 2 at negative PI
over 4 Y divided by X gives us negative
1 so a negative PI over 4 we're down
here at negative 1 at 0 we get Y divided
by x 0 divided by 1 is 0 so I'm going to
put a point at 0 at PI over 4 Y divided
by X gives us 1 and then at PI over 2 1
divided by 0 is undefined so you go
ahead and draw another vertical
asymptote and so if we sketch our basic
parent graph for tangent that's what it
looks like and then what happens is it
repeats ok like that going both
directions so this is just one period
one cycle ok so you're with me so far
so now if you want to graph this more
challenging graph what we can do here is
let's go ahead and figure out the period
first so the period is equal to PI
divided by B which in this case is 1/4
now remember when you divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so that's going to make this
period 4 pi so what I like to do is I
like to draw my graph ok and I like to
look at the period and I like to divide
it up into quarters into fourths so
basically I'm going to do is I'm going
count by 4 pi divided by 4 which is pi
so 1 pi 2 pi 3 PI 4 PI and so on and I'm
just going to go here to the left
negative pi negative 2 pi negative 3 PI
and so on now notice the X minus pi this
is actually going to shift the graph
right pi the plus one is gonna shift the
up one so what I'm going to do from the
origin imma shift right PI up one I'm
gonna think of this as my new origin or
my new starting point ok so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna I'm just going
to draw in like a little dashed or
dotted line you can draw this really
light on your paper okay like this but
we're just gonna use this a reference
point or as a starting point now what
we're gonna do is we're going to focus
in on what's left here
okay the parent function and you see the
negative value what that does is it
makes all the positive Y values negative
all the negative ones positive so it
reflects it over the x-axis so what
we're gonna do now because we know the
period is 4 pi and remember how we
talked about half the graphs to the
right of the y axis has to the left if
you take 4 pi and cut it in half that's
2 pi so if I go right to PI from here
that's going to be where our vertical
asymptote is right there if we go 2 pi
to the left that's where our other
vertical asymptote is okay like so and
then what we can do now is normally the
graph would go up to the right but
because it's reflecting it's going to go
down to the right so by going right 1
I'm gonna go down 2 and so that's going
to be one of our key points here and
then if I go left one I'm gonna go up 2
and so and then if we go right here is 0
0 so basically what we're gonna do here
that's 1 period that's 1 cycle of our
graph so that's an easier way to work
with it it's think about you know
shifting that origin that starting point
also calculate your period by doing pi
divided by B then take that scale K and
divide this period into 4 pieces and
then make that your scale and then what
you can do from here calculate where
your asymptotes are half's gonna be to
the right of that point has to the left
and then you can you know sketch your
other points from there so if you want
I'll have links to other videos I did
talk about how to graph tanjit some of
the more basic ones this is a more
challenging example if this helped you
you know subscribe to the channel give
it a like a thumbs up and I look forward
to helping you in the future of math
videos I'll talk to you soon